in fact hurricane irma is smashing tiny
islands in the eastern caribbean with
185 mile per hour winds early video
shows just part of the destruction the
category 5 storm made its first landfall
overnight on the island of barbuda a
government message from nearby antigua
ended with the words may god protect us
all irma is the most powerful atlantic
hurricane ever measured outside the
caribbean or the gulf of mexico it's
expected to pound the virgin islands
puerto rico the dominican republic and
haiti during the next 48 hours those
islands could see more than a foot of
rain and storm surges up to 20 feet high
our correspondents are in the caribbean
and florida where irma is expected by
sunday we begin with tony decouple in
san juan puerto rico which is bracing
for landfall in just a few hours tony
good morning
good morning that wall of clouds behind
me is the first sign of irma here in
puerto rico the winds are already
starting to pick up and later today
within hours the eye of the storm is
expected to be about 50 miles off of
this coast battering the capital of
puerto rico hotels are folding up their
operations stores in town are boarded up
or completely stripped clean of supplies
this hotel is using plywood and sandbags
anything to keep the water out and the
governor warns that this storm could be
more dangerous than hurricane harvey
irma slammed the northern leeward
islands overnight including antigua
barbuda and st martin bringing powerful
winds and coastal flooding president
trump has declared a state of emergency
in puerto rico and forecasters say the
island hasn't seen a storm the size of
irma since 1928. when hurricane felipe
killed nearly 3 000 people this time the
governor has preemptively opened dozens
of shelters and i can tell you for the
3.4 million residents of this island the
big concern as the rain starts to fall
here is toppled power lines and
buildings the head of the island's power
company warned that when irma comes
through here dark spots could exist on
the island for between a week and six
months nora wow that's difficult tony
decoble in puerto rico thank you so much